when i was in the air force i was just
in the air force
politics wasn't a big part of our
day-to-day operation and i would argue
that
largely speaking today throughout the
services politics still
is not a big part of what they do
however there's been a
momentous shift during the past calendar
year
to begin offering not just annual
trainings but
monthly and weekly and daily
conversation in some basis depending on
where you work
about race related issues they're
politicizing discussions not unifying
discussions
they're divisive discussions because a
lot of the language of critical race
theory
is being invoked something that the
american people hadn't heard a lot about
in the past before the past calendar
year but are beginning to hear a lot
about now
and as i recognized those discussions in
the form of what we call diversity and
inclusion trainings
uh stand down days uh both locally and
and also department of defense wide i
recognize
just how divisive this these discussion
points were going to become
as our down days and trainings were
starting to translate into
white and black airmen for example
starting to be skeptical of one another
based on what they were being trained to
believe
asian-american airmen coming to me and
explaining that they're tired of all of
the black versus white rhetoric and that
they're deciding to get out of the air
force
white airmen coming to me and saying
they're deciding to separate
from the from the air force or space
force because they're tired of being
accused
of racism constantly so this is the time
period
the last calendar year that i've
recognized these things really starting
to heat up
and that's been true across broader
society but also in the services
is there a single event that caused that
or was it a because there's a big
difference between a
sudden tipping point and just a gradual
you know build up to hey where did you
show up out of nowhere you're sitting
here telling me i'm racist i don't have
any problem with anybody i just want to
make sure you're performing
how did this show was it overnight or
was it gradual
the reason that's difficult to answer
properly
in my view is because the answer is both
it is both gradual and it is sudden
marxist communist
subverse subversive tactics require
years if not generations to properly
germinate for the soil to be properly
prepared for people's
willingness to divorce themselves from
what would be considered traditional
values
and that kind of thing takes a long time
there's a reason
those who understand and are intent upon
pushing that agenda target the education
system specifically
higher learning but also now the public
education system our churches
uh those institutions
are places where from a very young age
to our adult life we continue to be
educated and influenced
and if you can if you can plant subtle
ideas
over a long period of time all it takes
is certain tipping point
or crisis events as you pointed out to
capitalize on
in order to begin revolutionary changes
within a society
one such event it's just a matter of
fact i know it's controversial but was
george floyd's death
what i saw in broader society and
incidentally in the military services
this past calendar year was that that
event
was capitalized on by those who are
activists
for uh whether they realize it or not a
marxist agenda
black lives matter and antifa for
example have marxist dames
uh there are many compassionate people
who participate
in uh these various efforts because
they're compassionate and because they
are interested in bettering the lives of
humans but what they don't understand
is that the inventors
of or creators of the ideology and the
agenda have
a particular aim in mind in its division
not unity
it's uh it's revolution
not peaceful unification of society
so if you like this sort of short club
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye